when did you start finding your own
voice
uh for your writing
i don't know that's a that's an
interesting question i mean you
when you start out as a writer
you're very much more influenced by
the things that you you read right and
as you continue to read
hopefully in a broader and broader uh
genres and areas and styles
you're you're always encountering
writers who are doing new things and
and you're wondering can i do that too
so
you know you can see in some of my early
works heinlein influence you can see me
trying to do ursula k le guin you can
see several efforts of mine to do jack
vance who i so admired to capture their
voice at least see if i can do it
and and uh these are all
improving your craft kind of things you
you want to learn to
can you use this tool can you use this
technique can you use this voice
at some point in the in the evolution
there you do develop
your own voice but it's not a conscious
thing it's a
it's a evolutionary thing and after a
certain point you
in your life in your career as a writer
you you stop
trying to imitate other people and just
start trying to tell the story
with all of these techniques that
hopefully are are now at your disposal
i think a lot of writers do that today
as fan fiction
what do you think about fan fiction
well it depends on how you define
fan fiction i mean i wrote
in in the 1950s and 60s
what we then called fan fiction which
simply was
fiction stories written by fans and
published in fanzines in amateur
magazines
but the stories were wholly original i
wasn't writing about anybody else's
characters i was writing about
characters that i created like uh manta
ray
and garrazan the mechanical warrior and
the white raider uh you know my own
superheroes of my teenage years
and they might have been influenced by
some of the superheroes that were out
there but they were they were my own
they the stories were my own everything
was my own
um and i'm all in favor of that i mean
you know
fanzines i don't know what their modern
equivalent is there must be things on
the internets but the old dittoed
fanzines and mimicry fans in my youth
were
a great and important part in my
development
not only me but of many many young
writers
and comic fans at the time
today fan fiction has come to mean
something very different it's come to
mean
taking the characters from an
established franchise like star wars or
star trek or
harry potter and writing original
stories of that i'm i'm not in favor of
that i'm you know it's
it's a copyright violation and uh
i don't think it's particularly good for
the franchises to have this kind of uh
derivative fiction out there and and i
don't think it's
good for the people writing it if they
aspire to be writers i mean
to be a writer you you need certainly to
master storytelling and prose but you
also need to master world building
and character creation if you're
borrowing all your characters and you're
borrowing the world
you're never gonna you're never gonna
get those aspects of your craft and and
be able to arrive at the point where you
can
create your own worlds and create your
own stories